les cherry lyly à un voleur dans
l'équipe à il y à vos leurres dans
l'équipe
voyez votre vos mains je tiens bien sûr
la vérité ce soir pour nos
téléspectateurs et je vous le dis il se
trouve qu il est un voleur je vous le
dis mais d'alim est-ce que vous avez
déjà volé dans les loges de tpm paix a
pas encore août sur le plateau à part
prendre des sodas non non ce que vous
avez déjà vu l'envolée non castaldi à
moi j'aimerais lecoeuvre jamais quoi il
est né vers 9h30 9h30 de leur mort je
crois que je ne connais même pas la
définition du mot mais jamais à moi oui
ça m'est arrivé
quoi alors des cotons manama un vrai vol
alors à des lingettes
non non
[Applaudissements]
là où est ce que vous avez déjà volé au
geipan à ses volets ce à partir de quel
montant
c'est qu'il y ait un voleur dans les 15
mois le voleur non non c'est pas moi oui
s'il est vraiment là non la volée kelly
vely on sait désiré garder à boucler
ouvre en est sûr
[Musique]
chez moi
[Applaudissements]
venez donc vous coller j'ai un problème
c'est quoi c'est que j'avais très loin
de paris a aucun magasin qui sont
ouverts le soir tard et comme je n'ai
jamais rien à manger chez moi je suis
obligé de hachette avant de venir on a
bien compris il y aura une sanction chef
ou pas je pense qu'elle va devoir
rembourser toutes les caennais qui
d'autre poker est bien la preuve en
images elle n'est pas toute seule
effective
dimanche si un beau football fr
à
oh
unia
[Applaudissements]